[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANDELION MANE: I always wind
up doing these live demos,
so I never get the privilege
of just jumping straight
into slides, and so there's some
amount of computer wrangling.
But [INAUDIBLE]?
All right, so my
name is Dandelion.
I'm the only person I know
who has an emoji signature.
It's the dandelion emoji
and then the lion emoji,
although I didn't actually
put this on the slide.
And I'm here to talk
about TensorBoard.
So TensorBoard is a
really exciting tool.
It's been built by a number
of engineers at Google.
And the basic idea
behind TensorBoard
is everyone knows that
neural networks can sometimes
be a bit of a black box.
And so we want to
TensorBoard to be something
of a flashlight,
something that will
let you take the confusing
world of TensorFlow
and start to dive into it.
Now it's a pretty
complicated tool.
It's got a lot of
bits and pieces.
So the way that I'm going
to explain it to you
is by going through an example.
So we're going to take
a simple MNIST model.
It's going to have a
couple convolutional
and pooling layers at the top.
And then it's going to have
two fully connected layers.
And then it's going to
spit out our prediction.
And we're going to just build
this model together and explore
what can go wrong and how
we can use TensorBoard
to better understand it.
So I'm about to show
a bunch of code.
I'm going to go through
it kind of quickly.
You don't need to worry
about getting all the code
right now because it's posted
on my GitHub as a gist,
and we'll also tweet
out the link at the end.
So to start, let's put together
some layers in TensorFlow.
So we wanted to have
a convolutional layer.
So we're going to
make two variables.
These will have the
weights and the biases.
We're going to then apply
the convolutional op,
we're going to apply a
reLU to the convolution
plus the biases, and
then we return that.
Then we're going to make
a fully connected layer.
This is even simpler.
Once again, we have
weights and biases.
We're going to do the reLU
of the matrix multiplication
and addition, and
we return that.
Now that we have some
layers, we can set up
the feed-forward
part of our network.
We have some input placeholders
which we'll just take
in our images and our labels.
We'll reshape the image so that
it actually looks like a 28
by 28 pixels so we
can convolve on it.
Then we'll start putting
together our layers.
We've got the two
convolutional layers.
We flatten it, we get the
two fully connected layers.
And that's basically
our whole network.
And finally, we need
to compute the loss
and start to actually
train things.
So we're going to use cross
entropy for our loss function.
We're going to use an Adam
optimizer to do the training
step.
And just for convenience,
we'll record the accuracy
so that we can print
that out to the console.
So finally, we just need
to do a little bit of work
to turn this model on.
We're going to iterate--
we're going to initialize
all of the variables.
Then we're going to do
2,000 steps of training.
For each step, we're going
to take an [INAUDIBLE]
of the MNIST training data.
Occasionally, we're going
to report the accuracy
so we can see if it's working.
And then finally, we'll
run the training step.
So we have our model.
Let's turn it on.
At zero step, it
has 10% accuracy.
That seems about right.
At step 500, it
has 12% accuracy.
Not exactly what
we were hoping for.
And then it even goes down.
And we can see really, this
model didn't learn anything.
It's just getting baseline
10% by random guessing.
So what are we going to do
about this broken model?
Well, I just said we
have a flashlight,
so let's turn it on.
And the first thing
we might want to do
is visualize the computational
structure of our TensorFlow
graph.
Because we spent all
this code setting it up,
but what if it's miswired?
What if somehow we just
didn't make the connections
or the computation we expected?
So we're going to need
something called--
we're going to need a class
that lets us write data
from TensorFlow to disk so that
we can read it TensorBoard.
And that class is
called the FileWriter.
It basically just
writes any information
you're going to
visualize in TensorBoard.
And to visualize the
graph, it's very simple.
We set up the FileWriter.
We give it a directory.
And then we add to our
sessions graph to that writer.
And now finally, we just
turn on TensorBoard.
It comes pre-installed
in the PIP package,
so you can just, at
the command line,
write TensorBoard
and pass it a logdir.
And that brings us to our
first demo, which is here.
So it has no scale or
information, has no images.
The only thing we
gave it is a graph.
So we can go to the graph tab.
And we get something that's
really quite confusing.
So I can kind of see
how this corresponds
to the graph we made.
Because maybe we see on the
left we've got a convolution,
we've got some addition, we've
got a reLU, we've got pooling.
But it also has all of
these parts that I really
don't have any idea where they
came from even though I just
made the graph myself.
So what we're seeing here
is that TensorFlow graphs
are really complicated.
And the way that we can get
this tool to actually give us
useful insight, we need
to do a little bit of work
to structure the graph.
So essentially, we need
to clean the graph.
Now you may know that every
TensorFlow graph is based
on this naming system
where it has these ops
and the ops have names.
We can control the names
by giving individual nodes
specific names and by setting
up names scopes, which
cause all groups of related
ops to have the same naming
structure.
So let's go and apply that
to the model we just built.
First, in our layer
definition, we're
going to take a couple
ops that are important,
like the variables, and
give them explicit names,
like W for Weights
and B for Biases.
And then we're going
to apply name scopes
to the entire layers so that
all of our convolutional ops
will stay grouped and likewise
in the fully connected layer.
Then, when we actually
set up our graph,
we pass a couple of more names,
like giving the placeholders
names.
And we use this function to
give name scopes to our layers.
And finally, we add a
couple of names scopes
to the training and the loss
computation and so forth.
So now that we've
done that, we can
construct another summary
FileWriter pointing
at a different directory.
You always want to use
a different directory
with TensorBoard to
keep data separated.
And we can turn on TensorBoard
pointing in that directory.
And now we get a
much nicer graph.
So you can see here
that this actually
starts to correspond pretty
meaningfully to the graph
that we had in mind.
We have this
training block, which
is connected to everything.
That's because when you are
computing the gradients,
you need to connect to
every variable in the graph.
But maybe for now we'll
move it to the side
because it's not as
interesting to us.
And now we can kind of
explore and say, OK, we
have our x placeholder.
We reshaped the data.
Then we go through each of
these convolutional layers
where we have some variables.
We have the convolution
and the addition.
And we can kind of
scan through a graph
and see that everything is wired
up the way that we expected.
Now, I'll point
out a few features
of the graph visualizer.
One thing is, as
you've noticed, you
can explore different layers
of levels of abstraction
by diving into
individual pieces.
And we can dive in further.
And here, we're
getting the mechanics
of computing cross entropy.
It turns out all of
this sliced stuff
was for computing cross entropy.
Also, you'll notice
that different boxes
have different colors.
The way that the graph
visualizer works is it
identifies repeated, similar
substructures of the graph
and gives them the same color.
So we can be sure that these
two fully connected layers have
the exact same
structure as each other
because they are
both colored green.
Now this sounds
like it might not
be such an important feature.
But actually, when
we were porting
the inception graph
over to TensorFlow
back a year and a half ago--
and this is a very complicated
graph with tens of thousands
of nodes, we were
stuck for weeks.
And we were getting
the wrong results.
And we actually thought maybe
TensorFlow was just broken.
Maybe we had spent like a year
developing this new software
and it just wasn't
going to train.
And it turned out the real issue
is that one of the inception
submodules had a slight bug.
So it was wired
slightly differently,
and that was breaking
the training.
There are a couple of other
settings you can use here.
So, for example, we can
look at coloring by device.
In this case, everything
was put on the same device
so it's all gray.
But if you were using
a mix of CPU and GPU,
you can use that to get an idea
of where things were placed.
We can also turn
on trace inputs,
and then you can choose
any individual piece
and kind of see what all of its
dependencies are in the graph.
Everything else gets grayed out.
So yeah.
But from looking
at this, it does
look like we have, more or
less, the graph we expected.
But as we saw, it's
not training at all.
So it's time to get a little
bit more information and time
to start using these other tabs.
Now to do that, we
need to actually write
data, runtime data,
from TensorFlow to disk.
And the way we do that
is through a system
called summaries.
A summary is basically a
special kind of TensorFlow op.
It will take in a regular
tensor from your graph,
and then it will
output protocol buffers
that we can write to disk.
Now, there are a couple of
different kinds of summaries.
The simplest is the scalar
summary which will just
write down a single
value, and you
use it to create these
nice line charts.
Then there are image summaries,
which we'll write out an image.
And you can use it to
visualize, for example,
if you have a generative
model of images,
or if you just want to
check that your input
data is formatted correctly.
We have an audio summary.
So, for example,
the magenta team,
which we'll hear from
later and is working
on a lot of music
generation actually
added the audio
summary to TensorBoard.
There are histogram
summaries, and these
let you look at the
shape of distributions
of different values.
So it can be very nice to
be attach to your variables,
like your weights.
And finally, we have
the TensorSummary.
The TensorSummary is
the newest summary.
The idea is that it can
write out any kind of value
because everything in
TensorFlow a Tensor.
But we haven't quite added
support for it fully yet.
And I'll discuss it a
little bit when we get
to TensorBoard's future plans.
So now we'll add a
couple of summaries.
We had these two
scaler summaries,
because it would be
nice to look at how
the cross entropy
and the accuracy
are changing over time.
It would also be nice to
look at our input images,
just make sure that they're
MNIST digits, like we expect.
And then, finally,
in each of our layers
we'll add a couple
histograms that
will show us the weights, the
biases, and the activations.
So with that all said,
we need to think, OK,
how are we actually going
to run these summaries?
And the answer is that
we run each summary op.
It gives us the
protocol buffers,
and then we can pass them to our
FileWriter to get them to disk.
It would be really
tedious if we needed
to keep track of those
six or seven summary ops
and run them all individually,
especially if we'd
go to a graph like Inception
that might have hundreds
or thousands of summaries.
So instead, we have
this Merge All summary
that creates a single target.
We run it, and we get every
summary in the whole graph.
So we can go and create
another FileWriter.
We can go and modify
our training code
so that it will run the merged
summary and write it to disk.
And then, finally, we just
need to turn on TensorBoard
pointing out our new directory.
So now we can start
to explore what's
really happening in this model.
So as we saw, the accuracy
bounces around 10%.
In the backdrop, you can see
the original data is very noisy
because it's just got random
sampling moving around.
So we can smooth it to see
the trend line more clearly.
And then we also have
the cross entropy.
And this is pretty interesting
in that the cross entropy is
staying exactly constant
throughout the entire training
run, which is just something is
seriously wrong with the model.
We can also take a
look at the Images tab.
And here we find OK,
our images actually
do look like fine MNIST images.
And we can look at
a true pixel size
and then be reminded that--
something went wrong with that.
But you also expand it.
So we have a couple of
different capabilities here.
And what we'll see
really interesting
is when we look at the
distributions and histograms.
So this is actually
two different ways
of visualizing the same
histogram information.
The distribution
chart is telling us
that all of the values
were stuck at zero.
And the histogram chart
is going to tell us
the exact same thing.
All of our activations were
one giant spike at zero.
And also, all of our biases
and weights were stuck at zero.
So this gives us an intuition
that something was probably
wrong when we set up our layers.
Because when the biases
and weights are all zero,
we're going to have
zero gradients passing
through the graph and
nothing will train at all.
So let's take a look
at our code for where
we set up these layers.
I'm going to look at
the convolutional layer,
for example.
And you can see that we actually
set the biases and weights
to initialize at zeros,
which was a mistake.
So we can change that to have
a more sensible initialization,
like a truncated
normal for the weights
and a constant value
for the biases.
And now we can just
rerun our model
with the changed settings.
And we start to get
much better results.
We can see here that our
cross entropy rapidly
decreases towards zero.
And our accuracy rapidly
increases towards one,
or perfect accuracy.
If we want to see these two
charts at the same time,
we have the ability to
create groups of charts
using regular expressions.
So we could put everything
in one chart, in one group.
Similarly, we can now see that
if we look at the histograms,
for example, we actually have
nice distributions over time.
Sidebar about these
histogram visualizations.
They were made by the
really talented Shawn
Carter, who used to work
at the "New York Times."
and he was inspired
if you've ever
seen this album cover
called Joywave, where it's
like an audio wave forms
spread out over time,
he's the kind of guy who sees
an album cover and thinks,
ah, that would make a
great visualization.
So we can do a
couple of cool things
here, like we can switch them
from the offset to overlay.
So sort of if you want to
see how it evolved over time,
the offset is useful.
If you want to see how it looked
in absolute and relative terms,
the overlay is quite useful.
We have the exact
same information
in the distribution
charts, where now it's
showing us a different
view, where we can see,
for example, this very pale
line is the maximum value.
So we can see that there
was a very high maximum
value for the activations.
But here, we're looking at
like the 90th percentile
and the 60th percentile.
It was actually fairly
closely clustered.
But the important thing here
is that our model is finally
working.
And we can see that it's
training a lot better.
So now that we have a
good model, we might say,
OK, well, we chose a learning
rate kind of arbitrarily,
and we chose our model
architecture kind
of arbitrarily.
But what if we had done
things differently?
What if we tried a couple
of different learning rates
and what if we had tried a
couple of different model
architectures?
TensorBoard can be really
useful for this as well
because it gives you
a good way to compare
how different versions
of your models
stack up on all of these
different variables.
So we can make a couple
of changes to our code.
We're going to iterate over
three different learning rates.
And then we'll
iterate over using
one or two fully
connected layers
and one or two
convolutional layers.
And we're going to
make a unique string
for each of these hyperparameter
settings describing it.
For example, learning rate,
underscore, 1e negative 3,
then fully connected equals
2, and then convolutional
equals 2.
And we'll create a
new summary writer
that's pointing to
a directory that
has that string in the name.
And now we can
actually run the model.
And we're going to point
TensorBoard at the parent level
directory.
So in the past,
we've been pointing
TensorBoard at the
directories for specific runs.
And now we want to look
at the parent of runs
so that it can find all of this
data and compare it for us.
So now we can go
to our next demo.
And here, we have this
run site on the left
has got all of these different
hyperparameter settings
that we experimented with.
And now we can look at, for
example, our cross entropy
and start to see
how they compare it
across the different runs.
Similarly, we have
accuracy up here.
So we can see, actually,
there was a lot of variance.
Some of our models barely
learned anything at all,
and some of them were
extremely successful.
If we look at cross
entropy, maybe we
want to make things
a little bit clearer.
Like the beginning
everything starts high,
so it rescales the display.
So we can zoom in, and we get
things a little bit clearer.
We can also toggle on a
logarithmic scale, which
makes the differences a
little bit more pronounced
and sometimes very useful.
And then we can start
exploring with our tool tips
here and seeing, OK, this
run that was the worst
was learning rate negative 3,
and then both convolutional
and both fully connected.
And this one that was the
best was the same thing
but with a smaller
learning rate.
And if we want to do a
more in-depth comparison,
we can start to filter
by settings here.
So if we want to look
at all the things
that had only one
convolutional layer,
we could type conv
equals 1, and now
we can see just the ones that
had one convolutional layer, so
that makes it a little
bit easier to dive it.
Or similarly, we could search
for only the things that
had the learning rate
of e to the negative 4,
and that includes our best run.
A couple other features
I'll point out.
You can also just toggle one
run at of time by clicking here.
And we can also
change the display
to show us different
ways of visualizing time.
Right now, we're orienting
the x-axis by step.
But we could do it by,
for example, wall time.
And then we can see, actually,
that while they're all
aligned in steps, I ran
them at different times.
We can also use
relative time, so this
will show the number
of minutes from start.
And then we can see, actually,
that some models took a lot
longer to run than others.
So even though they took
the same number of steps,
the models with
more fully connected
and more convolutional layers
ran about twice as slowly.
And then we can also visualize--
all of our other displays
also give us more information.
So if we wanted to
look at all the biases,
we could see how they
varied for different models.
And let's see, conv
1, slash bias, maybe.
And so that's kind
of interesting
that we can see the
different models actually
had very different
patterns for how
the biases evolved over time.
And probably by
digging into this,
we could learn some ways in
which the models are actually
structurally different.
Similarly, in the
graph visualizer,
we can explore the
different runs.
So we can see here
that right now we
have one of the models
that had only one
convolutional layer and only
one fully connected layer.
But we could go and compare it
to different models instead.
So the final thing--
major feature from TensorBoard
that I'm going to describe
is the embedding visualizer.
And it's maybe the coolest
piece of TensorBoard.
What the embedding
visualizer basically does
is it lets you take
high dimensional data
and then project it down
into three dimensions.
Now the way in which we might
be really interested in doing
this is when we take
our input data set
and we map it through the
neural network, to say,
the final layer, that
embedding is actually
the learned representation
of how our neural network is
processing the information.
So I'm going to throw a
bunch of code on the screen,
and I'm not going to
explain in great depth.
But I will say there's
a wonderful tutorial
on the embedding
visualizer on the website.
But basically, what
we're going to do
is we're going to
make a variable that
will hold the embedding of
each of our test set images.
And then we're going to create
a configuration object that
has a little bit of
information like, where can we
find a sprite PNG of
all the MNIST images
so we can display
thumbnails in the browser?
And where are we
finding the labels
so that we can
organize the examples
by which label they are?
And then we write this all
to disk using the FileWriter.
And now, every 500
steps, we're going
to save a model checkpoint.
And this model
checkpoint contains
all of the variables
in our model,
including that
embedding variable.
And then, finally, we turn
on TensorBoard once again,
pointing to this directory.
And here we have our embedding.
This is 1,024 points
from MNIST that I decided
to use from the test set.
And what we're
looking at right now
is the principal components
analysis of the embedding.
So we've taken the top
three principal components
and laid out these points in
three dimensional manifold.
So if we color by
label, we can already
see that it's learned a pretty
useful separation, like all
of the ones that have
been separated on one
of the principal components.
And then there's kind of
one principal component
has the 9s and the
7s, which makes sense
since they're kind of similar.
And then on the opposite end
of that principle component,
you have more like
2s and 3s and 8s.
But we can do even
better than this.
We can use my personal
favorite feature here,
which is [INAUDIBLE].
So this is going to
go and reorganize
the data set so that it
preserves local similarity.
And then we get this
really cool visualization
that shows us which
pieces of data
were locally connected in the
manifold, in the embedding.
So we can see, for example,
that the 1s got really
nicely clustered on their
own, which makes sense,
since 1s are very
distinct digit.
And we can see that it has
a little bit more trouble,
for example, with the 3s
and the 8s and the 5s,
because those are a little bit
closer and a little bit more
intermingled.
And we can even start to
dive into individual examples
where the model made
a bad prediction.
So if we look, for
example, at the 7,
it's clustered with the 1s,
so that's almost certainly
a test error, whatever
it incorrectly
labels the 7 as a 1.
But as we zoom in on
this particular 7,
it really does kind
of look like a 1.
It's probably the
oneiest 7 that I've seen.
So it makes sense that the
model's making that mistake.
And similarly, if
we look at this 9,
it really looks like a 1.
This 4, I think, really is a 4.
So maybe the model just
has an issue there.
The embedding
visualizer can also
be used for a lot
more than just images.
So it's really useful for
visualizing vocabularies
as well.
And I'll actually just
show you an example.
This is the smart
reply data set.
So every time that's
your inbox app
suggests saying
thank you to someone,
it's using this dataset.
And we can see here that we
have exclamatory statements
are over here.
Like please confirm now,
please confirm you got it.
And then this access has
less exclamatory stuff.
And we can even do stuff
like creating our own axes.
So if you know the
king queen example,
where you take a word to
[INAUDIBLE] embedding.
And you set one axis
is king minus queen,
and then you find
it has learned a lot
of gender-related concepts,
you can interactively
explore relationships like that
using the embedding visualizer
by defining your axes
to be the differences
between different words.
So I'm almost out
of time, but I'll
talk a little bit about
the future of TensorBoard.
We're going to be, in
the next quarter or so,
integrating the new TensorFlow
debugger into TensorBoard.
So that means you'll start
to be able to use the graph
visualizer to do things like
get an immediate view of where
there are any NaNs or infinities
anywhere in your graph.
And if so, when did they appear?
Or you'll be able
to use the graph
visualizer to click
on individual tensors
and visualize them.
We're also doing a bunch
of work on plug-ins.
If you remember, I said
we're adding a new summary
op that can write out any
kind of data in TensorFlow.
And the idea there
is that we can
start to have people
contribute visualizations.
They'll be really specific to
a particular problem domains.
So if you go to
distill.pub, you'll
see that Chris Olah
and company have
made amazing visualizations for
inspecting handwriting models
or for inspecting
speech to text models.
And we want to be able to
incorporate these really
domain-specific visualizations
into TensorBoard,
and we're going to do that by
making it easy to add plugins.
And finally, we're
creating something
I'll call organization
scale TensorBoard.
Right now, as you
saw, TensorBoard
is something that
one person locally
turns on, on their own machine.
And we're going to create a
scalable, production-sized
instance so that your
entire organization
or your entire
research group could
share a single
TensorBoard and then
share results easily and
keep a history over time.
So that's it for my talk.
The codes and slides
are on this link.
It's also on my
GitHub, Dandelion Mane,
and I think we'll
tweet this link out.
And so next I'm going to
introduce Martin Wicke.
Martin is undoubtedly the
most handsome, best dressed,
and most intelligent
person on the team.
And he's also my boss.
[LAUGHTER]
And he owns all of
TensorFlow open sourcing
and he's going to tell
us a bit about new APIs
that make doing all of this
MNIST code much easier and much
less complicated
than in my example.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]